[Music]
how many superheroes are in this movie
superhero rock superhero 30 you
wondering why you're on set you were
like what is going on here were they
hiding woods would you know we've ever
curious every day because every day we
never we rarely got a script really more
than a few pages and half of the stuff
was your dad yeah like I really have a
video like no we don't know if we're
gonna do all that and then the next half
was like yeah and then and then it would
change anyway whatever you read then the
big 20 new replayed pages okay so how
many trailers were there it will really
tell trailers for as far as the I had
the Mac he called you an institution of
trouble way to me was an institute for
trouble yes good trouble good trouble
okay the wood is changing
also for the first time in 35 years in
Saudi Arabia they're opening to my
cinema and they're opening with Black
Panther now what do you think you know
it's just astounding you know I mean and
that's that's a pretty fantastic thing
and you know from what I've heard that
was the response was fantastic and so I
mean it's it's it's pretty it's pretty
amazing to see that sort of opening as
he said you know occur you know through
this vehicle yeah that's fantastic
have you taken a moment to realize that
you're going from one of the biggest
movies of all time to probably the
biggest movie of all time we learned
that as an actor man you don't really
like project too far into the future
though yeah stay in the moment you stay
in the moment this in this experience it
was more about being present and playing
with with the actors that you read that
you respect and you know trying to see
what they're gonna bring in the scene
and because a lot of it again we're
learning on the spot you know it's not
like when we're studying the script at
home as much as we would have a normal
situation what learning what's gonna
happen on the spot and then looking at
each other like how we're gonna do it in
there there so it's um you know you
getting the chance to play with with
what you feel like are the best people
under stress though but having fun at
the same time like everybody's joking
around everybody's you know this
Mackey's doing things practically
sometimes you know way but it gets
serious once once they say action what
is going on in Wakanda that there's
always so much trouble there or at least
that there
that was like Julie open up doing nine
and you guys I think that there is
actually something you know the beauty
and the power of wakanda is that it has
a lot to offer and so you know it being
involved in a very epic moment it makes
a lot of sense but of course that's
gonna come with its complications but
you know it's it is all about that that
what we established in in in the stand
alone which is this is it's time you
know and with that comes it's almost
like I think you know what Condes is is
called upon to deal with the trouble
that is in the rest of the world reality
yes it's not like we it's not like this
trouble that we're kind of we're all
guessing because this is so daggone
secret you know yeah I mean have you
ever been part of a project wrapped in
such secrecy no yeah so which is one
person you could tell stuff to
definitely not
although they're always building me for
information alike so what happens that
way we've got exchanged numbers of the
cast maybe the top need to talk to each
other each led by the cone of silence
our basic I don't even sell it the cast
members know like what do you mean that
telev what yeah it is it is marked out
I'm like I don't know who else can get
that screw you know
[Music]